Humans have always been explorers.
As a species, we are innately curious about
what lies beyond our horizon.
If the day ever comes when we embark across
the cosmic oceans beyond our moon, what vessels
will we use to discover new worlds?
Few art projects capture the wonder and awe
of voyaging to an unfamiliar planet better
than the ‘Explorer’ series.
Brought to life by incredible digital artist
Christian Grajewski, the story is set in a
distant future, where the remnants of humanity
journey to a lush exoplanet called Aion.
The ongoing ‘Explorer’ project doesn’t
just examine a vibrant alien ecosystem, but
also documents the fascinating vehicles the
early explorers use to chart the unfamiliar
planet.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
tag along with the first wave of explorers,
and voyage across this mysterious world in
a range of different machines.
And as always, you can follow and support
the artist using the links in the description.
Now, let’s set off towards Planet Aion…
We set out from Planet Earth on the Ourea
— the greatest construction project in human
history.
And after a brief journey of three-hundred
and seventeen years, we arrive.
To explore planet Aion up close, we must leave
behind the safety of the mothership.
Landing on the planet’s surface, for the
first stage of our expedition, we’ll be
traveling in the Ant, a compact research vehicle
that will make exploring Planet Aion safer
and more efficient.
Setting off from our landing site, it’s
not long before we spot our first lifeform.
Stooping for a drink in a shallow creek are
unique, bipedal herbivores.
They’re tall — over two and a half meters,
or nine feet, and have an elegant appearance.
Like earth deer, they seem rather skittish
— bounding across the terrain as we pass
by.
A few of them stand their ground, not interested
in abandoning their prime watering hole.
Using their two lower horns, they begin to
produce a rattling noise that seems intended
to frighten away predators.
But perhaps it isn’t us that these deer
are scared of.
Emerging from the underbrush are the first
predators we’ve seen on this planet.
These are the Silent Death, and they are built
for the chase.
Like cheetahs, their aerodynamic bodies are
capable of incredible bursts of speed.
Similar to many lifeforms on Aion, the Silent
Death lack eyes, instead relying on sonar-like
echolocation.
Soon, a chase will begin between predator
and prey — a drama known to most planets
with complex life...
Driving through a marshy swampland, we can
spot a rather singular looking lifeform.
These bizarre herbivores are a member of the
Formaminis Caput classification — a taxon
marked by the sizable holes in the middle
of their skull.
Getting a closer look at this alarming gap,
we can see the hole serves as an enormous
olfactory organ — with sensitive hairs giving
the creature an incredible sense of smell.
An extreme — yet effective — anatomical
feature.
With their long snouts and tongues, this species
somewhat resembles an anteater.
The exact function of their tongues isn’t
known, but likely helps them snag their preferred
food source from the swampy water.
Yet in this marshland, sticking your tongue
in the water can be dangerous.
From the murky depths, a menacing predator
lifts themselves on two muscular arms.
With a length of eleven meters, or thirty-six
feet, this semi-aquatic lifeform is the largest
carnivore we’ve seen so far.
Like the alligators or crocodiles of Earth,
these patient hunters ambush their prey from
the water — drowning them or swallowing
them whole.
Their snake-like bodies make them excellent
swimmers, and their strong arms paired with
their spring-like musculature allows for explosive
movements.
Passing near the water’s edge is a risky
venture...
Yet one titan in this watering hole pays little
mind to what lurks below the surface.
This is a Stag-Beetle Rhino, and they spend
their days combing through the swamp in search
of tasty vegetation.
Curiously, their breathing organ is at the
highest point of the tail, helping them stay
underwater for longer.
Strange as that might sound, various Earth
beetles breathe through spiracles in the rear
of their abdomen.
When plodding through the swamp, Stag Beetle
Rhinos use two antennae on their backs to
create whip-like sounds that warn predators
to keep their distance.
For no species wants to end up on the receiving
end of their horn…
For the next stage of our tour, we’ll need
to travel in something that can handle all
manner of terrain.
The Monkey is a futuristic research vehicle
suitable for the most challenging environments,
and will take us into the teeming forests
of this alien world.
And speaking of monkeys, in the branches above
us are the Aion equivalent of primates.
The Odellion is a somewhat odd-looking herbivore
that feeds on the foliage of the high canopy.
Like the woolly monkeys of the amazon rainforest,
moving from branch to branch is second nature
to the Odellion.
This field sketch shows the Odellion’s method
of traversing the canopy — a locomotive
strategy that might look backwards to us,
but serves them well.
Curiously, the Odellion seem to lack teeth
altogether, instead opting for long, muscular
lips — a trait that helps them pluck leaves
off the high branches.
Deeper in the forest, from the bank of a forest
stream, a brightly-hued creature is watching
us.
This is a Toxicorum — a mid-sized predator
with highly poisonous skin.
Like the vivid colors of a sea slug, the Toxicorum’s
coloration is aposematic — warning other
predators against taking a bite.
And if a Toxicorum subdues their prey, they
drink their victim’s internal liquid using
their tentacles.
We’re fortunate to be behind protective
glass...
Among the flooded roots of the forest is an
exceedingly rare gathering.
These bizarre creatures are Magna Caputs — and
there are just a few thousand of them left
on this planet.
Their giant heads can make a deep drumming
sound when threatened, and house highly sensitive
receptive organs.
Typically solitary, the Magna Caputs will
call out to each other over thousands of kilometers
during breeding season, and come to congregate
in forests like this one.
We’re lucky to be able to observe such an
infrequent ceremony.
But it’s best to give them some privacy…
In a dense region of the forest, a standoffish
looking creature blocks the path of our vehicle.
This is a Turtleneck, a solitary lifeform
that — despite being an herbivore — is
an aggressive bully that doesn’t tolerate
intruders.
Like rhinos, Turtlenecks will charge any lifeform
they deem a trespasser.
Two shield-like protrusions protect the sides
of their body — and seem to envelop their
heads.
These shields can change from soft and flexible
to hard and rigid in an instant, and allow
the Turtleneck to ram into their targets at
high speeds without risk of injury.
Our best move is to take the long way around
the Turtlenecks’ territory.
In a nearby clearing, a small flock of bipedal
omnivores hiss at our vehicle as it passes.
These pint-sized creatures resemble alien
chickens, although instead of a beak, they
possess a muscular hole for a mouth surrounded
by four frenzied tentacles.
Like Earth shorebirds, these generalists scavenge
often for food.
They’ve become unexpectedly fast little
creatures in pursuit of small insects that
are the alien chicken’s favorite food, which
this field sketch illustrates.
To aid in this endeavor, their tentacles are
sticky and act like flyswatters, bringing
insects directly into their gullet…
To chart the next region, we’ll be traversing
in Crickets — lightweight helicopters capable
of vertical take-off and landing.
Try to stay close, for we’re passing through
an area home to the largest megafauna on this
planet.
Looking up at us as we pass overhead is a
herd of Bone Heads.
These bellowing behemoths possess a triangular
hole in the middle of their head that serves
as an olfactory organ, marking them as another
member of the Foraminis caput classification.
Like hippos, the Bone Heads have evolved to
spend most of their time partially submerged
in water, which helps support their significant
bulk.
Connected to the Bone Heads’ hollow skulls
are flexible, fishing rod-like trunks they
use to catch aquatic lifeforms.
For the Bone Heads are omnivores, feeding
on all manner of underwater organisms to stay
satiated.
Turning westward, we can spot a noisy procession
of Circulus.
Another type of Foraminis caput, their circular
head gives them the ability to make a unique,
loud call.
The distorted shape of their skull amplifies
the noise — although the result is a face
that looks rather unusual by our standards.
The Circulus also possess two tentacles that
they use for smelling, navigating their environment
with their keen olfactory senses…
Not far from the Circulus procession, a group
of clumsy and colorful looking bipeds slurp
from the muddy water.
These are Anguis Collums, and they are on
the small side for this region — at about
one meter, or three feet.
These omnivores might be unassuming, but they
feed in a somewhat unsettling manner.
As this field sketch shows, the Anguis Collums
use their long tongue to dig into mussel-like
creatures, then blow poison into them and
wait until their soft tissue becomes liquid,
which they then drink.
A disquieting way to get a meal, although
nature is often unforgiving...
Snow and harsh winds block our path to the
north, so we’ll hitch a brief ride in the
massive Frog — a mobile research lab that
moves on wheels over fourteen meters, or forty-five
feet high.
In a vehicle like this, we’re ready for
anything.
And it seems we’ve attracted the attention
of something equally massive.
This inquisitive giant is called a Gantor,
and they seem puzzled — but not particularly
bothered — by our presence here.
At nearly twenty-five meters, or eighty-two
feet in length, Gantors are an incredible
species to witness up close.
Yet even more impressive than the Gantors’
sheer size is their remarkable intelligence.
Gantors possess two trunk-like appendages
that play an important role in their communication.
During mating season, they seem to use their
tongue for some kind of sign-language, to
impress and “talk” to their favored partner.
Exactly how intelligent Gantors are is difficult
to ascertain, but it’s possible we’ve
just made first contact with something very
special...
To venture further out into the unknown, we’ll
be taking to the skies once again in lightweight
aircrafts called Geese.
Don’t let their unusual shape fool you — these
crafts are fast and agile enough to get us
an up-close look at the rarest lifeforms.
Trumpeting at us while we pass overhead is
a herd of what appears to be alien elephants.
Yet what seem to be large ears from a side-view
are actually massive bone structure surrounded
by soft muscle tissue.
Their unusual skull also contains a large
hole — marking them as another member of
the Foraminis Caput classification.
Like the Circulus, this unique head acts as
a powerful sound amplifier for the thunderous
calls of these alien elephants — calls they
use to connect over vast distances.
For unlike the social elephants of Earth,
these curious creatures spend much of their
lifecycle all alone...
Landing for a moment to stretch our legs,
we make an unsettling discovery.
Not far from our position are three Citus
Mortems — the most dangerous hypercarnivores
on planet Aion.
The aerodynamic shape of these terrors allows
them to make tight turns when pursuing a target
— and reach blazing speeds.
Like Earth tigers, their efficient musculature
helps them take down prey many times larger
than they are.
Yet unlike tigers, these predators hunt in
coordinated packs.
And with the strongest bite force on the planet,
the Citus Mortems have no natural enemies.
Our best move now is to get back in our vehicles
and fly in the opposite direction.
Back in the skies once more, we pass over
a valley home to the single largest land animals
on this planet.
This is a herd of Tortugantus, creatures that
from tip to tail are over one hundred meters,
or three-hundred feet in length.
Witnessing a Tortugantus is like seeing a
god walk upon the soil of a planet.
With such massive bodies, the Tortugantus
herd spends most of their days finding food,
mainly in the form of vegetation.
Herds like this one can contain up to fifty
individuals, and are remarkably close knit
— as the intelligent Tortugantus are capable
of feeling empathy for their fellow herd members…
For the final and most spectacular leg of
our journey, we’ll be traveling in the top-of-the-line
Hornets.
These vessels can travel vast distances without
stopping — which is important, for we’ll
be flying over the planet’s ocean.
On the rocky coast, a somewhat unusual group
pays little attention to our passing crafts.
These are Snail Frogs — agile and rather
playful omnivorous creatures.
Their upper and lower body have sail-like
structures — which seems to be used to make
the Snail Frogs look bigger to predators,
and to impress fellow members of their species.
Like Earth snails, Snail Frog stalk eyes are
capable of 360-degree rotation, and they give
the species a distinctive and somewhat amusing
looking appearance.
Snail Frogs primarily feed on mollusk like
creatures in shallow tidepools, which they
scratch from the rocks using their powerful,
four-part jaws...
Moving out to sea, we can spot our first fully-aquatic
lifeforms swimming just under the surface.
Chasing a group of fish-analogues are the
Triangulus Stingray — pursuit predators
with slim, aerodynamic bodies.
Like Earth Stingrays, they possess barbs capable
of producing venom.
Yet the Triangulus Stingray’s possess three
forward-facing barbs instead of one in the
rear — which they use to spear their prey.
With their triangular wing shape, these hunters
can stop almost immediately, or change direction
when pursuing a meal…
Further out to sea, a larger, more terrifying
creature dwells in the depths.
Up to eleven meters, or thirty-five feet in
length, these predators prefer to hunt in
the colder reaches of planet Aion.
Nicknamed Alien Seals, these lifeforms are
swift in the water.
Like Earth seals, however, when they come
on to land, they can’t do much but flop
about.
Some say these alien seals look quite peaceful
when lying on the shore — although this
sight is difficult to imagine, considering
how menacing they look when prowling the dark
depths.
We can be glad we’re not in the water…
Yet the air doesn’t seem safe either.
A flock of huge flying creatures soar just
behind our Hornets.
These are Red Deads, and with a wingspan of
almost 30 meters, or 100 feet, we might be
in serious trouble.
Yet despite a name that suggests aggressive
behavior, Red Deads are actually quite peaceful.
While from time to time they do have aggressive
fights with rivals — hence their nickname
— these majestic beings aren’t here to
pick a fight with us.
Like dolphins accompanying Earth boats, Red
Deads are naturally inquisitive, and are flying
alongside their new airborne ‘mates’ out
of sheer curiosity.
Little else is known about these beautiful
red beings, although given their size, they
likely have no natural predators.
Soaring alongside this flock is a special
privilege…
Yet our voyage is not over yet.
Breaching near the surface are the final lifeforms
we’ll be observing on this tour.
This is a family of Immanis Cetacea — the
largest living, moving creatures yet discovered
on this planet.
Dipping under the surface in an underwater
pod, we can see that like baleen whales, these
leviathans comb the oceans with their giant
mouths and eat everything that comes their
way.
Yet at over one hundred and ten meters, or
three-hundred and sixty feet in length, they
make even the largest earth whales seem rather
small.
In the unspoiled oceans of Aion, families
of Immanis Cetacea lead calm and peaceful
lives.
And as incredible as it’s been to get close
to this species, we don’t want to disrupt
said lives.
The time has come to head back…
Journeying through the ecosystems of Planet
Aion has been fascinating.
You can discover more of the incredible vehicles
featured in this video in Christian Grajewski’s
‘Explorer’ artbook — which I’ve got
a link to in this video’s description.
There are big plans for this universe: as
Grajewski is working with other creatives
on a novel and a screenplay — and is also
planning to release a second artbook that
will focus on the creatures and narrative
of this exciting world.
To stay up to date on the project, follow
and support Christian Grajewski using the
links in the description.
I’m excited to see where the story goes
next…
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.